ah oui j'adore la danse oui et voilà on
retrouve des amis et c'est vraiment une
première qui est très très sympathique
pour nous voilà c'était le rendez-vous
attendu par tous les amateurs de danse
rétro le thé dansant organisé le 4 mai
par la mairie de plaisir dans la salle
des fêtes des gaâtines une salle
entièrement rénovée un vrai orchestre
beaucoup de monde présent des danseurs
des danseuses qui n'hésitent pas à venir
d'autres communes pour leur passion
dan rtro depuis 2008 je danse et
j'apprécie j'essaie d'aller dans les
salles que je connais plus ou moins le
bouche à oreille me fait venir un petit
peu partout cha tango Vals Mambo les
danses s'enchaînent près de 120
personnes sont présentes des passionnés
de danse mais aussi des nouveaux
danseurs pour d'autres simplement une
sortie une occasion de se retrouver
entre amis l'orchestre encha les succès
dans on se lance on s'amuse ou on répète
avec sérieux les pas de danse appris en
cours un succès pour cette première
édition que la mairie souhaite bien
évidemment renouveler la prochaine
édition aura lieu le 1er juin nous nous
retrouverons une fois par mois après la
pose estival donc nous reprendrons cette
fréquence à l'automne changement de
rythme changement de partenaire parfois
les plus motivés ont ainsi pu danser
pendant près de 2 he cette nouvelle
activité à plaisir semble enchanter tous
les participants qui reviendront le mois
prochain avec
plaisir